[Music]
wedding speeches they give you sorts of
anxiety and stress for many it's an
important occasion and if you get it
wrong you might ruin everything but we
have a fix for you we've used science or
if not science at least art and we have
some techniques that we're gonna share
with you that will guarantee that you
end up with a funny memorable and
inspiring speech if you follow our
simple recommendations so first I want
you to imagine that you got the call you
weren't expecting it you thought you
should would be a guest eat a lot of
cake maybe some pie but it turns out
someone fell ill and you have to now
write a speech or a toast take whatever
it might be how do you feel a little
flustered a little concerned maybe not
ready so imagine your friend who again
loves rotary telephones and has a
traditionalist about this wants you to
give this speech you're the maid of
honor the best man whatever it might be
what are you gonna do what's the worst
that could happen it turns out a lot we
talked about a 1 you might end up in a
Twilight movie but more seriously it's
an important moment where you're gonna
have the attention of a lot of people
and you need to use that attention
effectively to bring everyone together
in a powerful way so what we have here
is a better process which we think will
deliver you a better outcome this is
these are my actual friends it's not a
stock photo illusion an angel I didn't
give the speech at the wedding but those
who did follow this recipe and they're
happily together that's really the best
I can promise at this point but I know
that it went well so we're gonna talk
about three things today
first how you could write that speech
what the structure the skeleton of it
should be like how you can pick the
stories that will be effective number
two how you lead the audience how you
can tell it some techniques and diets on
the emotional journey and then number
three some proof points about how we
know this works personally and how
powerful it is
so without first writing so how to write
it first to understand the objective the
objective of the wedding speech is to
just a couple to the audience so make
sure that you're speaking to the room
not on behalf of the room and also at
the same time always remember this is an
occasion about the couple it's not about
you so in terms of constructing the
speech there's a simple set formula that
we can follow and it's called 3 1 2 what
is 3 1 2 stand for you might be
wondering so I'm here to tell you 3
stands for third person when you open
the speech you want to share a story
funny story or a warm memory about the
couple if you there are certain
personality traits that you want to
convey to the room always such as
loyalty or sense of humor always tell it
through a story because stories are
easier to remember and then make longer
lasting impressions so give yourself
some time to think about what you want
to tell the room it could be when the
couple first got together or if there's
something that stands out in their
relationship or you might pick up a
memory that you and your friend ie the
bride or the groom share with each other
or share with you and make sure you tie
it to the wedding so that's three one is
your emotions
it stands for first person this is a
time when you share your your own
feelings about the couple and tell it to
the room say something like it fills my
heart with joy to be here today
two stands for a second person this is
when you turn to the couple you address
them directly and wish them best on
their journey together and you wrap up
your wrap of your speech with the simple
toast to the future pretty simple right
well actually one more thing
we recommend that keeping the story
short and simple is the way to go
because and we think about five minutes
is probably around the perfect amount of
time for you to tell one or two stories
long enough to get your points across
but short enough to maintain guests
attention
but on a second thought after this class
we're all going to be incredibly
captivating public speakers so this war
might not apply to you okay now we have
the method to put up at a content but
how to lead the audience and deliver the
content to the audience we design
another framework called emotional
emotional journey based the delivery
let's look at them so for the first
phase we will talk about a funny funny
story or memory as mentioned before the
story on memory is about a couple about
you your job here is to lead attention
from the audience to the couple and the
emotion and and you want to evoke
emotion from the audience that are like
what that is so interesting
I felt so touched I've also moved today
if you can do that you went for this
wrong it's absolutely fine for you to
talk about some anecdote like let me
tell you the groom used to run Nicolay
around the campus to celebrate the whole
world final and only after he got off
the coast he noticed he had another exam
over the next week or something touching
while looking for Hillary another
rotifer Trump after one year they are
still together and this there still want
to get married today
okay fur for the second phase you want
to share your feeling it's your time to
share your personal feeling at that time
you are the delegates for audience if
you're feeling can represent emotions
sentiments of the audience you make this
stuff down you're feeling could be like
a confession to the to the to the man I
I just want to marry you as though
instead of being your best man or
something like looking at it in person
of her face where you're naked that was
truly my best moment in my life okay for
the last face last face of emotional
peak it's the best time for you to smile
authentically or cry often tele or smile
and a crisis mutiny ously and
authentically if you can do that
however never smile only because you're
fake crying is too funny making wishes
in the last phase require authenticity
from bottom of your heart so with your
true heart please join me to wish the
true love for the couple for this one
precious life and a human life after
this all right so what what I'd like to
do is talk through a story when I
actually had the opportunity to use this
three-on-two framework to deliver a best
man speech for my college friend Jason
and his wife Liza my situation was a
little unique because I had not met Liza
until the weekend of the wedding so I
had to modify some of this framework for
Story 3 I told a story about Jason and I
when in college he convinced me then a
super awkward very uncoordinated
engineer to take the lead front and
center dance spot on a routine that he
had choreographed to Britney Spears as
oops I did it again do you recall this
is this is her outfit there so from the
day of the performance moving forward I
turn I transformed from this awkward
socially uncomfortable engineer to an
awkward socially uncomfortable engineer
that could dance and Jason always told
me that I should always remember that he
created me and then I should always
remember to give credit where credit was
due I promised him at the age of 20 that
I would never forget where I came from
and I made good on that promise during
my speech in this section of the wedding
telling him Jason I just want you to
know I've never forgotten everything
you've done for me and the fact that you
empowered me to achieve new heights that
I never thought were possible I took the
extra step to connect it to Liza to say
I know the two of you have the ability
to empower each other to do things that
neither of you knew were possible before
you met each other section 1 my emotions
trust the couple my observation in
meeting and seeing their dynamic over
the weekend is they argued consistently
but always managed to come out with some
sort of agreement that was significantly
better than were either than it started
at the beginning the argument so I spoke
to the inspiration in the hope that I
felt for relationships just
in general and seeing how they were able
to emerge from arguments and truly bring
out the best of each other for section
two a second person inspiration of the
audience I was in a unique situation
where Jason's family spoke almost
exclusively Cantonese and Liza's family
spoke only English so in order to bridge
the gap between between these two
parties what I did is I memorized for
wedding proverbs in Cantonese and
English and recited them one by one in
each language and I saw the eyes light
up with the audience as they heard the
Proverbs and their own single language
and then invited everybody to raise a
glass to the future of Liza and Jason
either the combination of the two
languages being spoken or the britney
spears anecdote brought everybody
together as everybody was very motivated
go to the dance floor immediately after
and the two families who had been
relatively separate previously shared a
moment of connection on the dance floor
Jason debuted his amazing dance skills
for Liza Stanley for the first time and
they became all the more convinced that
she had chosen the right man to marry
one year later I received a phone call
from Jason indicating that he and Liza
had chosen to name their firstborn son
Matthew after yours truly clearly a
testament to the strength of the three
wants you framework so the three once
you framework can enable you to develop
a speech that is memorable inspirational
and funny for the wedding couple that
you were that you were speaking to and
connecting them to their audience and if
you're lucky you may just get the name
of their firstborn child in the process
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]